make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're gonna be covering x-men
later on this week kind of getting back
into the swing of things or at least as
best we can without there being any real
new comic releases I think they're like
Marvel and DC or doing some digital
stuff but much like the rest of us
Marvel and DC are just kind of flying by
the seat of their pants in terms of how
all this is gonna how this is gonna work
and all that kind of stuff this really
is an unprecedented situation but what
we have here at least what we're gonna
do and you know and today we're gonna
cover of course Ultron forever now
Ultron forever is kind of an unofficial
sequel and not relieved in a sequel kind
of a spiritual successor to a story
called Avengers Forever and Avengers
forever was an old school story not
really super old-school but like a
turn-of-the-century
story from from Marvel there really
focused on the idea of Avengers from
like different points in time all coming
together to fight it fight a particular
foe but what this does is it basically
picks up at some point in the future now
it simply says the year is 2000 and
something-or-other right we're not given
a definitive date but what you have here
is the golden skull which basically kind
of seems to be a sort of successor to
the red school but obviously some kind
of a super criminal here now what we're
met with is this versions or this this
timelines version of Captain America
which is actually a chick named named
Danny Cage now we'll find out you know
that here in a little bit for right now
we can kind of throw it out there it's
not a major focal point but of course
basically I mean she goes as far as to
say like you know my father's Luke Cage
my mother's Jessica Jones now Danny Cage
is kind of an interesting character
because she's been depicted in different
ways over the years if I recall
correctly she did appear during the
events of old man Logan this is one of
the more interesting roles where she
became the new Captain America now how
that happened we're not explicitly told
here there there is a story out there
that I believe focuses explicitly on her
origin somewhere in Marvel Comics but
it's actually kind of interesting right
it's just a future version of that
character which is always sort of cool
now these photos are taken out quite
readily and as soon as she goes in for
you know to take out the golden skull
then suddenly she's whisked away and
that's really kind of the common theme
that we're gonna see going on here that
you've got Avengers Tower and you know
and at least in the present day as ice
given to us but you've basically got you
know black widow kind of doing her thing
hanging out with vision and so on and
really just the two of them kind of
engaging in a training situation a
training simulation but much like
Captain America in the future you know
Danny Cage they're whisked away as well
only for us to find out the person who
did this is Doctor Doom now those are
guys who are exceedingly familiar with
Marvel
you probably immediately like I did you
looked at that that rectangle-shaped box
that was basically taking them away and
immediately saw it as dr. Doom's time
platform right in Marvel Comics those
you guys who don't know Doctor Doom has
mastered the ability to travel through
time the issue is that time is one of
these things where the smarter you are
the more you understand how you
shouldn't screw with it right that's the
reason why Wolverine who's kind of an
idiot started messing with time and
screwing things up during age of Ultron
because he's just kind of a he's kind of
a goof in a lot of different ways right
he just kind of goes in guns blazing
that kind of a thing whereas Reed
Richards was kind of like we can't screw
with time and that's really why dr. doom
doesn't use the time platform all that
often he's let me ever use it a few
times over the course of Marvel because
going back and changing time for which
spiral out a litany of alternate
realities right in the future would say
the same so it's one of these things
where like like with Days of Future past
as a really good example that with Days
of Future past the idea was okay we're
gonna go back in time we're gonna stop
the assassination of Charles Xavier more
McTaggart and Senator Robert Kelley and
and basically prevent the future where
the Sentinels conquered everything but
the issue is that because they came from
that future
you can't come from a place that doesn't
exist right so that future has to exist
the result is that you know they're they
essentially created a new timeline where
Days of Future past never happened
that's kind of the issue that you run
into when you when you talk about
manipulating time and Marvel Comics but
ultimately what Doctor Doom is done is
he's brought together Avengers from
different time periods you guys will
probably recognize James Rhodes as Iron
Man he was Iron Man at one point way
back in the 80s of course we've got
Danny Cage who comes from the future the
funny thing is the Incredible Hulk as
you see him here is actually before the
Avengers were founded right so this is
way back essentially the original
Incredible Hulk and then of course a lot
of the guys will recognize Jane Foster
Thor now the funny thing about this is
that this story being written in 2015
basically coincides with the time when
Jane Foster became Thor in Marvel Comics
and we got one of the best store runs of
all time in the sense that like original
sin in 2014 was basically Thor losing
the ability to wield his hammer right
and that's kind of the funny thing that
goes on here is because as soon as they
basically realized this is Doctor Doom
they immediately attack now in the
middle of fighting him suddenly you have
these kids and this guy America Connor
kind of comes running out of nowhere
and there is sort of like okay there are
kids who are running to the to the to
the aid of Doctor Doom what is going on
here and so once everybody kind of
begins to calm down then what you get
here
is really a kind of meet-and-greet from
these various Avengers who were here and
so of course you have you know vision
you have Incredible Hulk you have these
folks meeting each other Danny Cage
introduces herself to to a Tasha
Romanoff basically saying like I know
you are we've fought alongside each
other for quite some time
Natasha Romanoff is like yeah I know who
you are but like you're six months old
and then you have the meeting between
Thor Odin's son and Jane Foster now
here's that here's the cool thing we're
actually gonna see a kind of a kind of
nod to this later on but it's one of
these funny things where like initially
this kind of discussion on like the
death of Thor or you know the death of
Odin son or something along those lines
and ultimately you know that the kind of
discussion here is basically agreed that
at some point along the line Odin's son
passes the hammer to somebody else now
the funny thing about this is Odin son
assumes that he passes the mantle on
right that like you know something
happens to Odin and Odin ever recovers
from the Odin sleep or something like
that then he dies and Thor basically
says okay I'll take the place of Odin
and then basically says like we need a
new Thor and then somebody else has
chosen to be that person Odin son you
know because he's from the past does not
know that he's going to lose his ability
to wield his hammer and that's what's
kind of cool about all this you know if
you get this really really cool nod
later on but essentially with everybody
kind of coming together and saying okay
you know like like sinner heads are
prevailing dr. doom tell us what the
world is going on but essentially Doctor
Doom starts talking to everybody and
basically saying at some point along the
line Ultron basically rose to power now
here's the funny thing about this Ultron
essentially returns and managed to kill
all the superheroes but one of the
supers who superheroes who is dead is
star brand now the reason why Al Ewing
has done this is because at the time
when this story was written the full
totality and the nature of star brand
had not fully been explored by Marvel
Comics yet it hadn't been explored by
Jonathan Hickman at this point in time
star brand was just kind of already
there and we were getting to the closing
act of Avengers and new Avengers now if
you guys recall once you got to the
closing act once you got to the final
act and you had the battle between hyper
oh yeah I guess Hyperion Odin Sun star
brand Knight mask and then and then the
beyonders that's when you got the full
explanation that Kevin as star brand has
as much power as he needs to face off
against whatever threat he's going to be
fighting at the time this was written
that wasn't the case we didn't know if
that was the case and so the result is
that you basically just kind of had okay
you know star brand essentially shows up
here star brand is taken out just like
everybody else because they haven't been
established that he had an infinite
amount of power
that if Ultron shows up he could take
him out but there's also other scenarios
that are being implemented here right
we're basically told this is the
ultimate version of Ultron Ultron
already had an adamantium shell right so
far brands power is more of kind of
grunt force right he's not really a
reality manipulator he's not like
Franklin Richards right it's just enough
power to destroy a particular thing but
adamantium cannot truly be destroyed in
Marvel Comics because it's essentially
the most durable metal in all of
existence and so aside from like being
able to break it down on the molecular
level using something like anti metal
vibranium or using reality warping
abilities to control the atomic
structure of matter there probably
wasn't really a way for star brand to
destroy Ultron in the first place
something else funny that you see here
down in the very bottom right hand or
left hand corner you see Robocop but
what we end up learning here is that
essentially what had happened is that
after Ultron had destroyed the entirety
of the superhero community every single
superhero on earth did following that he
in turn basically went through and
started creating like this just litany
of Ultron robots right so it's very akin
to like age of Ultron meets like
Terminator with Skynet just like
spawning an army of terminators to take
out what was left of humanity the
difference here is that much like the
Sentinels from Days of Future past with
Ultron it was overwhelming force Ultron
was way beyond the Sentinels right just
in terms of capabilities and whatnot
like a singular Ultron could have
destroys all the Sentinels during Days
of Future past
he's exceedingly capable here but after
that what he ended up doing is after
creating all these different Ultron
robots I kind of solidify his reign that
those individuals who rebelled those
members of the superhero community who
didn't die in the original skirmish and
were discovered to have survived by some
strange means in turn they basically
tried to overthrow Ultron and they were
basically brainwashed right their minds
were completely wiped and in turn they
became servants of Ultron himself this
basically happened across the board with
humanity right like he man of themselves
only about 30 million people left on
earth and all of them are servants of
Ultron so there really is no free will
that exists anymore what he's also done
is he's kind of created these sort of
androids right artificial intelligence
organisms which he refers to as as
Avengers and actually uses the weapons
of the original Avengers which is kind
of a crazy thing to see but what Doctor
Doom is basically done is sat down it
kind of created this sort of a method to
ultimately defeat Ultron by analyzing
him by looking at him and realizing the
shortcomings of himself that Ultron has
essentially left
self opened when the group gets together
and they kind of start talking and
saying okay what's your plan dr. doom
basically says one of the big failings
of Ultron is that he is still very much
human in terms of his thinking the funny
thing about this story is that this tied
into Avengers number 31 right we saw
this future during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers we only saw a
glimpse of it but we saw a future where
like Ultron had conquered everything but
what you ended up having here is
basically Doctor Doom kind of creating
this multifaceted plan the first one is
- basically it's what the Avengers
really into three main teams the first
team of Ironman envisioned will
basically launch a frontal assault on
what was Avengers mansion and is now in
the main base of operations for Ultron
and of course you know as they make
their way in it's kinda like okay
they're gonna be the main frontal
assault they're gonna focus on on this
and basically draw the attention of the
various Avengers who were there the
problem with this is that once they
launch their attack they're immediately
overwhelmed right just like that they're
taken out with a quickness literally
James Rhodes gets shot in his chest
device and that basically ends up you
know powering down his entire suit of
armor like shutting the whole thing down
then you've got vision who's basically
overtaken by his by himself by his
future self as he seems to have been
manipulated or at least controlled by
Ultron and then you end up switching to
to the second team and the second team
was more of a strike team right it was
kind of it was falling in line really
more with the nature of Black Widow kind
of a black ops strike team this idea
that Ultron would essentially have two
main systems right he would have a
backup system and then he would have
like the main system they can take down
the entire basis behind this backup
system is to basically end up rallying
troops right that with Ultron's you know
kind of as he calls it the world wide
web but basically a system that
broadcasts messages of obedience and
control through the the various headsets
of those humans who are controlled by
Ultron and that destroying the backup
system and then destroying the main
system will take away Ultron's ability
to maintain his control over the 30
million humans who were left what this
means is that these individuals can be
either imbued with powers or can be
given weapons and arms and armament and
can basically wage war against Ultron
now at this point I would say it
wouldn't even really matter there's so
many Ultron robots you wouldn't really
think it would have a chance anyway
right like what are 30 million baseline
humans with some weapons and like a
handful of superheroes like against 30
million Ultron robots right like it
would be more than enough to wipe out
everybody here like you can even cut
that number by a 30th right and say like
a million Ultron robots is enough to
annihilate the rest of humanity
and all the superheroes who were here
that's really all you need and so what
say you basically end up getting into
this facility you end up having like
this this future version of Black Widow
facing off against all of them along
with a whole bunch of human servants now
the idea is not to kill the human
servants but to take out black widow and
one of the other things we end up
learning here which is really really
cool is that you basically have Captain
America she uses a thought-controlled
shield that her her shield is
anti-gravity and it's it's controlled by
her thoughts as opposed to Captain
America's shield which was just pure
vibranium and was literally just
ricocheted right it was just ricochet
and then bouncing back that kind of a
thing but what is up happening here is
that while this is a cool weapon in
terms of its design that basically this
future version of Black Widow hijacks
the thought patterns of the shield and
then takes it under her control throws
of The Incredible Hulk and decapitates
the Hulk and so finally you know with
this this team essentially looking like
they're falling quite readily right
falling with a quickness though what we
end up doing is basically jumping to
both Thor's and as they make their way
to the to the main base of operations
they end up passing through the bug to
the Bifrost bridge two Ultron's
seat of power and where Jane Foster
initially kind of looks at this it says
okay so like this is a copy of the
Rainbow Bridge and this is crazy he's
basically kind of rebuilt Asgard for
himself the Ultron controlled Thor jumps
into the fray and basically says no none
of this is what you think it is the
funny thing about this odin son is that
you look at this this future version of
yourself this future Thor and I imagine
that you probably believe that like you
pass the mantle on through some kind of
death and glorious combat that you die a
hero's death or you rise to become the
new ruler of Asgard to replace Odin but
there's some measure of honor you end up
passing the mantle on that's not true
you fall that's all that happens you
fall this future version of Thor
basically tells us what happened in
original sin that Odin son lost his
worthiness he lost the ability to wield
his hammer and a hammer in turn passed
on to Jane Foster right so it's a cool
thing to see because what he basically
says it's like I'm gonna let you in on a
little bit of a secret but I do this and
I enjoy doing this right there is a
greater truth to all of this isn't it
that's that's going on I do all this in
service to the throne of Asgard and I do
it gladly
right because my mission is to serve the
all-father and the all-father the person
who killed Odin and took over Asgard is
actually none other than Ultron Prime
himself but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]